here and there I think I'm more like MMA
and then uh like I don't religiously
follow but maybe I mean it may I do and
then probably women's darts
women's stars
[Music]
all right so Major League Baseball is
kind of going through this strange
situation you guys know how they added a
pitch clock yeah no no where is that the
pictures are like yo step it up oh they
gotta go yeah they kept taking forever
on the mound like you just gotta you got
a limited time to throw it yeah so just
changing that one thing brought the
length of the game shorter by like 30
minutes whoa that's it was so still like
what five hours are they trying to make
it more quicker so people in like yeah
because it's it's like uh and it's I
think it averages like two and a half
hours now all right three two and a half
hours to three hours yeah that's a long
day yeah it is a long game though but
yeah
the weird situation with this is that
because now that the games are faster
stadiums are selling less concessions oh
[__] dilemma
less hot dogs and and to make matters
worse so the rule is for most stadiums
is that you're not allowed to serve
alcohol past uh the seventh inning or at
the seventh day oh yeah yeah so it stops
faster yeah so people can sober up
um and then drive home or whatever they
need to do but now that the games are
shorter you would think they would push
the sales back to the sixth inning but
instead they've allowed it to the eighth
inning
because it's going fast we're trying to
make up for it the thing is by the game
when the game's over by the time the
game's over you're drunk as [__] drunk
as [__] yeah yeah so you got a lot more
people driving drunk and uh some actual
Major League Baseball uh pitchers are
speaking out saying that it's putting
the fans in danger no it's not because
the fancy would be smart enough to drink
does this looks called tricky
responsibly God damn it are we all gonna
baby everybody now what's going on
what's going
on the world now but also like if it's
only gonna cut the game by 30 minutes
just just [__] take their time
pitching that's what I think like is 30
minutes gonna be that big of a day from
2 30 to 2. yeah like it's still a two
hour game
I think it's the pacing it's the because
like 30 minutes doesn't sound like a lot
but when you split that up between how
long a guy is taking to throw a ball
that's a long time like yeah 30 minutes
is just in the pitch but you know it's
part of the drama dude it's part of the
[__] yeah the drinking theme though
that's on the fans yeah it's like if
you're gonna drink go Uber to the game
or whatever you know or you got a
designated driver hold the [__] up but
what if what if innocent people get hit
by drunk drivers yeah no no no that's
the thing dude drunk driving is gonna
happen but it's like you can't control
what people they're gonna drink drink
and drive regardless you know what I'm
saying like this guy can't if you are if
you're the type of guy that's gonna
[__] drink and drive you're already a
wild [__] wolf yeah you're a wild
does it matter if the game is like three
hours long you're gonna probably leave
[__] up anyways but that's the same
it's kind of the same reason why places
have alcohol cutoffs at all like two two
a.m they stop serving it's so hard yeah
I know because people are still going to
do it people are gonna do it so they're
trying to limit their ability to make
that how do we make more responsible
citizens there you go
there you go you have to start with the
school
I don't want our leaders to do a joke
how do we make responsible humans let's
do prohibition but better because like
what in L.A you can't drink past two
right yeah
in high school all of my friends are
drinking and driving were happening at
like 10 or 11 because we're trying to go
somewhere so it doesn't whether it's two
or four a.m or midnight didn't matter
it's arbitrary like what he's saying
where it's just cars yeah if you're just
a crazy ass [__] you're just a
crazy ass [__] it doesn't matter
that's what I'm saying it's gonna be a
wild boy what if we had better public
transportation it'd be fine because then
there's less drunk drivers like in Japan
everyone just knocks out on the ground
oh true they get drunk and then you see
them on the floor yeah it's alternative
yeah the weird thing is it is an
opposite move though in terms of the
game got shorter so they're selling at a
later inning that is weird yeah because
they're trying to make up for the Lost
sale they would have gone which makes
sense but it's like and that's what the
Phillies pitcher Matt Strom is saying
he's like billionaires are still gonna
want to make their money they don't care
wait why don't they why don't they just
cut off alcohol but let them sell other
stuff because they buy food too right
nah now when those guys come in there
get [__] up dude how about this make
the game more exciting so they don't
have to drink whoa
isn't that part of the culture of
baseball games I've never been to a
baseball yeah you're just kicking it
you're just there to [__] around yeah
eat some hot dogs there for the beer hot
dogs and hanging you guys go to a lot of
baseball games no I do I do I own a lot
of games a lot of them which ones Angels
or Dodgers Dodgers well my girl works
for the Dodgers I have to go to the
games you have to so it's like a bombed
out about it your girl works at the
Dodge Studio yeah yeah so I have to be
at the games and stuff so I do not have
to but I go to the games and I'm like
but you still have fun yeah by myself
but I'm just like watching it and she's
working and stuff but I'm always I'm
just like yeah dude it's like to me it's
like I don't really I don't like sports
in general so I'm just kind of like I'm
just like all right cool cool no so
every now and then it gets exciting and
I'm just all right cool but for the most
part you know the waiting and and it's a
lot of foul balls and I'm like
another foul ball
in the Bright Stadium lights and then
make contact and then you know what I
mean but now I understand the game a
little bit more with like the batter in
the picture like Head to Head type of
thing so I get it now I'm like oh okay
see what's going on here I get the war
of attrition thing but I I just could
never get into it yeah just a little bit
slow it's like great game to play when
you're playing it it's fun well you're
playing it is fun but watching it is
like I'd rather play it's like watching
Jiu Jitsu I'd rather be hitting all the
league it was [__] pretty cool to
watch I do like it when the pitcher
throws the ball at the batter
it just beams him in the head like I
love the plays when someone's like they
they throw the ball to First and they
throw it oh yeah you know like I love
those exchanges you know but then it
calms down after that yeah but then it's
[__] dead right so my thing with
sports is like I'm the guy that's like
I'll watch any finals yeah yeah get me
to the final yeah and like in basketball
get me to the last game because all the
[__] seven [__] you know games six
games I was like why but they say that
the finals is watching all the other
games is what makes that one pay off
yeah that's because you know the story
this guy sat out for here this injury
but that's exactly it just give me the
preview of that
yeah I'm in I just don't want it to
happen but you just want the cliff notes
like the UFC UFC fight yeah
just like when they get to it I'm like
cool that's the storyline okay I'm going
in there not picking who I'm gonna
choose this last fight I I didn't I
didn't pick yeah and then when I heard
the [__] uh he kept beating him and
beating him and beating him and I'm like
what then I'm going for the other guy
what did I got to win yeah I wanted to
win I didn't know nothing about it you
watch a fight crazy right that was the
first fight I actually paid and watched
really what the [__] kind of fun right
because I wanted to see uh George
because I was [__] watching him since
I was like a kid sound like an X clock I
always watch them on YouTube and stuff I
used to be like beat people up yeah dude
you know I think I'm gonna get into
boring sports betting oh yeah because
then you'll start watching
um like college sports and [__] because
you're betting dude but that's the thing
I couldn't bet on this last fight
because it was I was in California uh
I'll give you a site I'll give you some
yeah dude because Bovada yeah Bovada oh
okay because I was like I want some
action what's going on it's a Latvian
betting site oh [__] thing about batting
for I think I'm just gonna think
DraftKings I did DraftKings [__]
drafting each other told me like sorry
dude cat you're a [__] common foreign
I think I'd get into sports more that
way are you a sports guy nah I liked
playing do you think you'd get into
baseball if you're betting
Last Resort
um there's so many other cool I'll
probably get into swimming before
seriously I guess it's a basketball yeah
I like here and there I think I'm more
like MMA and then uh like I don't
religiously follow but maybe I mean it
may I do and then probably women's darts
women's stars what's that maybe uh
basketball and then maybe boxing oh yeah
we should do a [__] three on three in
basketball let's play is there any
sports that you guys want to start
getting into let's go I'm down how is
there any sports you want to start
getting into like I think golf is kind
of cool because all my friends are
getting into it um soccer
me me I'm [__] I'm already playing
soccer uh golf I really got into it I'm
telling right now it's expensive but I
play like League soccer right now yeah
every Tuesdays and Thursdays which is
why I'm trying to go with this guy but
I'm playing soccer on Thursdays I'm like
[__] but uh and then I play golf but
golf is like it's pretty expensive it's
expensive to suck yeah like you're
you're you suck but you're paying like
yeah yeah I play [__] actual 18 holes
and [__] get the cart the whole shebang
uh go to the range and you [__] waste
another 20 bucks the range is fun have
you ever played foot golf have you seen
that yeah dude that thing is [__]
what I don't like about all the
restrictions you just kick it or
something yeah we had a kick it a
certain way you gotta hit it I'm like
probably here
yeah you can't just like hold her and
kick it you gotta like you have to kick
it like with the with the your point
are you not supposed to cut the kick
like that
I'm like okay like that they have it at
like seven golf courses they'll have a
full golf course and then it's like it's
the same thing with the golf yeah the
hole is like huge oh here's the frisbee
golf that's what I wanted it looks
pretty fun it's like golf but just with
um with frisbee well because didn't you
say ultimately there's different ways
really fun you said what did you say
ultimate frisbee is fun why did you
hesitate because
it's like it's like football but with
the Frisbee and rugby no it actually
honestly looks really fun yeah get that
queer [__] out of here no you can't
touch each other nah dude I want to do
the [__] freaking God there's
different weights on it let's play
Frisbee golf dude is there a course
around here I think they got a course
out here we should do something I think
I got into riding Sports more than Ball
Sports what about hacky sack hey you
know what's something
what's your thing like what's your thing
I like snowboarding and I like mountain
biking this isn't and then I think I'm
gonna pick up surfing dude I want to
surf so so so JK goes surfing so I try
to do surfing and Jesus Christ dude they
give you all these [__] things that
can happen and you're like yeah [__]
this that's the only reason why I didn't
do surfing and it's a 40-minute drive I
want to go do it and they give me a list
like oh you gotta sign this because this
could happen this can happen I'm like
it's a lot and knowing my luck dude I
will die out there when you're in the
water like like that I I feel like I'm a
pretty good swimmer you're a really good
swimmer but being out in the water like
that okay yeah like it's so scary but
like there's such a it's just so
peaceful out there you know what I mean
so it's like the whole time while you're
out there you're fighting this feeling
of like [__] I want to go back I want to
go back I want to go back that's that's
what I'm feeling when I go surfing but
then as soon as you're on the beach and
chilling you're like [__] I want to go
back out there yeah I want to go back
out what am I doing here this is
[__] I should be out there it's so
[__] what do you mean well it's like
you're just scared when you're out there
like anxiety and then when you're
sitting on the sand you're like oh I'm a
[__] for not being out there I should
be back out there trying to catch waves
you know so it's crazy such a good
swimmer that it doesn't make any sense
way better soon than I am and I'm like
if I don't have anxiety you definitely
should because if I'm drowning I'm not
counting to save my ass yeah shave us
all dude I this isn't a sport but I've
been I've been working on it a lot which
is going to be really gay but roller
skating really let's roller skate dude I
go I go like twice a week
okay you go backwards and [__] yeah
can't do the [__] like s legs and
[__] You're Gonna Roll the roller rink
and uh yeah dude let's go how do you
break up bro I will [__] go dude you
guys want to all go next time on Monday
oh yeah
I'm down dude yes I go on Mondays if you
guys invite me I'll go let's go you're
down yeah I'm [__] down what all
right we'll make it JK Adventure we'll
make it uh yeah okay for a roller
skating we better make out yeah [__]
twist
I'm gonna do the [__] in the Russian
yeah when I roller skate I like walk
ice skating get the [__] out of here
dude
[Music]
foreign